[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the federal trial of accused sarah
lawrence college cult leader the
prosecutor summed it up with three words
sex money and power our adam klassfeldt
has the latest from the courthouse plus
the deaths of lauren smith's fields and
brenda lee rawls i said to my sister
if brenda died we would have been
notified
and if she did where is she a new bill
is proposed to streamline death
notification protocol and inside the
courtroom for the sentencing hearing of
tv actor jessie smallett but first famed
black panther director ryan coogler is
arrested for withdrawing money from his
own account what's going on my man
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we begin with news out of atlanta
where a famed hollywood director is
falsely arrested for robbing a bank
that's right brian it happened back in
january when black panther director ryan
coogler attempted to withdraw twelve
thousand dollars from a bank of america
branch after that he was arrested body
camera footage of the incident was
released just this week it shows
officials arresting coogler after a
call about the alleged robbery according
to police reports when coogler
approached the desk for the 12-thousand
dollar withdrawal he gave the teller a
note requesting the money be counted
discreetly the teller later identified
as a pregnant black woman said there was
an alert on his account she told her
boss she believed he was attempting to
rob the bank after that authorities
arrived on scene to arrest coogler he
and his colleagues who were waiting for
him in a parked car outside were
detained body camera footage shows
coogler explaining to police why he
asked for the cash withdrawal via a
written note
basically we got a call and uh from what
we got the call it seems like someone
was trying to rob the bank
uh something about you passing a note to
the teller something to that effect
uh can you just tell me what's going on
it's a medical assistant that works in
my house that prefers to be paid in cash
every time i make a withdrawal to pay
her
you know because it's a large amount she
works a lot yeah
you know if i if i don't if i don't
write down on a note
how much i went out
and then i don't want to run through the
money counter right there at the desk
the whole bank ends up looking at me
because they just hear the money going
through the money
and i don't feel safe i don't feel safe
getting money out like that so every
time i go to withdraw it
you know i put that i put that mountain
yeah i want to take another
and i put my own card in
and then i and then i usually take me
out like oh it's just just get to get
the money you know what i'm saying
coogler was released shortly after he
was arrested at the time he did present
his id and bank card to the teller brian
terry joining us today is former chicago
area detective and swat member lisa
lockwood lisa where did this interaction
go wrong with coogler and
could have been corrected
it sure can and it comes down to
training so she was given a note but she
was also given identification and a bank
card the note made her skeptical and a
little concerned
but the problem was when she pulled up
his actual account she said there was an
alert nobody knows what that alert was
that flagged him for whatever reason and
she passed that information on to her
managers and then 9-1-1 was called so
i'm still in the dark regarding what was
the alert that made it appear to be that
this was a potential armed robbery i'm
sorry robbery in progress
and police responded adequately they
showed up because they said somebody
passed a note and as they were
ascertaining what was happening that
ability to look at the video footage
they needed to make sure everyone was
safe because it's very rare that you
have somebody who's burglarizing a bank
holding up a bank who does not have a
weapon so to go ahead and cuff him and
walk him outside and continue with the
investigation is all part of protocol
now terry we've talked a lot about this
case what's your reaction to this
situation as we learn more and more
you know it's unfortunate brian to say
the least it seems like a case of racial
profiling even though the teller was an
african-american woman and she basically
just came to the conclusion that coogler
was withdrawing money and he was trying
to steal from the bank even though this
was from his own account even though he
had his id he had his bank card he
didn't ask the teller to give her or
give him all the money he asked for his
own money so i definitely think that she
jumped to conclusion i agree with lisa
he should have been trained better and i
think it would be interesting to see how
many times 9-1-1 has been called in
instances like this yeah i think lisa
brings up a good point too i want to see
what the alert is because if it's an
alert that's just flagged but he has an
account to the bank and he has that much
money in the bank account then why call
the police alerts i know i mean i don't
have twelve thousand dollars to take out
of an account so i don't know what alert
comes up but we'll see how it plays out
as we get more and more information
and what's expected to be a lengthy jury
selection process continues thursday in
the federal trial of disgraced theranos
coo ramirez sunni balwani thursday marks
day two of jury selection for belwani
who faces 12 federal fraud charges in
relation to his time with the
now-defunct company theranos founded by
now convicted froster elizabeth holmes
theranos was touted as a company that
would revolutionize blood testing with
its state-of-the-art edison device later
tess found many problems with the device
in a federal trial spanning months
holmes pointed the finger at belwani her
former boyfriend and theronos business
partner holmes testified that bahwani
emotionally and physically abused her
prosecutors countered saying holmes knew
about the company's issues and lied her
way into millions of dollars in january
a federal jury found holmes guilty on
multiple accounts in bowani's case
multiple jurors have already been
dismissed for potential bias based on
the lengthy and highly publicized holmes
trial bowani has pled not guilty to all
charges his trial is also expected to
last for months
still ahead on law and crime daily
family members of late lauren smithfield
and brendaly walls call for new
legislation in the wake of their loved
ones deaths but first the jesse
smallhead sentencing here we take you
inside the courtroom for the first time
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
actor jesse smallett was back in court
he was once a rising star now he's a
convicted felon for claiming he was the
victim of a hate crime a jury found it
was all a lie law and crimes angen levy
is here with what happened in court
internet
brian this hearing started with jesse
smalletts defense attorneys asking for a
new trial they say his conviction should
be thrown out because his rights were
violated on a number of fronts smilet
appeared in a cook county courtroom with
a number of supporters and family
members a jury convicted smolette last
year of five of six counts of disorderly
conduct after finding he claimed he had
been the victim of a hate crime and
enlisted two brothers to help him
smollett told police he was attacked by
two men wearing red make america great
again hats and that they put a noose
around his neck and poured bleach on him
the story captured the attention of
millions across the country and chicago
police said they actually spent 130
thousand dollars in overtime to
investigate the hoax smollett testified
in his own defense but the jury didn't
buy his story judge james lin heard
lengthy arguments from both sides
the double jeopardy clause does not just
prohibit double prosecutions it also
prohibits double punishment
and
to punish somebody twice for the same
thing is a violation of the fifth
amendment
and here mr smallett was clearly
punished in the prior criminal
proceedings by the imposition of a
criminal penalty now certain people may
disagree with with
the severity of that punishment they may
they may not think that was a just
result but it doesn't take away from the
fact that he was criminally punished
your honor miss glandian is entitled to
her own argument what she is not
entitled to is her own facts
she stood before this court
and told you they raised the issue of
david elderbee's direct examination
nowhere in this 83-page motions did they
ever make a single complaint about the
examination of david elderly
ms glandian stood before this court and
told you that they made a motion to
recuse the whole office of special
prosecutor mr webb
myself mr weaver
nowhere
at trial or in his paper is there such
emotion and a special prosecutor
actually ended up handling this case one
of those special prosecutors said in
court that was because the confidence of
the community had been shaken in the
original handling of this case by the
cook county state's attorney's office
judge lynn declined and denied that
request for a new trial after that there
was a lengthy sentencing hearing more on
that on the next edition of law and
crime daily brian
thanks annette let's bring back former
detective lisa lockwood and terry austin
to discuss the sentencing of jesse
smallett terry the defense started its
arguments as we heard from angenette
with prosecutor misconduct and judicial
as well as trial errors requesting a
dismissal or new trial could we see
another bill cosby outcome on appeal in
this case
it's possible but i don't think it's
probable i think that the defense did a
great job at setting forth all of those
arguments for a new trial but the judge
would not hear it he said he had already
made decisions on all of those issues
there was no prosecutorial misconduct he
said that there was no way that he
abused any of his discretion as far as
the jury instructions were concerned so
i think some of those same arguments
would hold over for an appeal you have
to have a legal error for an appeal and
i don't think that she articulated any
legal areas where the judge in the
appellate level could overturn what was
going on so i don't see a ground for
appeal here i think the judge really
made some solid decisions and i think
all of those issues have been argued to
the greatest lengths including at this
hearing yeah now lisa guilty of five of
six charges i think up to three years on
each charge so what do you think is the
right sentence here and do you think any
of these impact statements are affecting
the judge
i would imagine yes as far as the impact
statements because you're you have a man
who has never been arrested no criminal
background he's a celebrity he's uh he's
on television and everybody's talking
about the good that he does but if we go
back to the other scenario of committing
this hate crime this hoax the national
attention that it garnered the media
tour that he went on talking about this
thing happening to him which turned out
to be a hoax in itself the racial
tensions the political tensions the gay
community tensions
it just went on and on ideally i would
say if i were judged sitting there of
course reimburse the chicago police
department for all the extra work and
labor that took them away from doing
what they should have been doing on the
street 130 000 and a minimum of six
months all right antoinette there was an
argument smollett's attorney made for a
new trial that seemed a little odd tell
us about that
yeah it was interesting because she was
saying he didn't have a public trial and
the judge responded to that by saying
this was the first trial i had during
covid and the media wanted cameras in
here and the defense jesse smallett and
his attorneys said no we don't want
cameras in the courtroom the judge said
that the media was allowed in the
courtroom and then the special
prosecutor also said look the whole
world could have watched this thing had
there been cameras allowed in the
courtroom so it was kind of interesting
for a tv star to not want a camera in
the courtroom for his trial yeah the
back and forth on that is interesting of
course we're still keeping eyes on uh
the jesse small that sentencing i i kind
of agree with lisa maybe some amount of
months may be handed down here but of
course as it drops we will be here to
give you the updates coming up on law
and crime daily testimony begins in the
federal trial for accused sarah lawrence
sex cult leader lawrence wray in new
york city our own adam classical reports
from the courthouse plus the deaths of
lauren smithfield and brendaly walt why
the families of both women are calling
for new laws in the state of connecticut
[Music]
welcome back after two connecticut women
died their families say police never
notified them now lawmakers are getting
involved in hopes new legislation can
prevent similar situations in the future
two black women lauren smithfield and
brenda lee rawls were both found dead on
the same day in the same city of
bridgeport connecticut last december
smith fields and raul's deaths were
ruled accidental but their families say
the circumstances are questionable both
families have criticized law enforcement
for failing to notify them about their
deaths the bridgeport police department
is undergoing an internal investigation
for how the cases were handled
connecticut state lawmakers have now
proposed a bill which if passed would
mandate officers to notify next of kin
within 24 hours of a deceased person
being discovered the bill was the topic
of a public hearing before judiciary
committee on wednesday family members of
both women had the opportunity to speak
i support this bill with the hope
that no other family will have to go
through the following
tuesday december 14
2021
my daughter jessica came to my home
and told me that they were going looking
for my sister brendaly ross
later on that evening my sister angie
called me and said
the guy brenda was with says she died
sunday morning december 12
2021 at his house and the coroners came
and got her body through the family's
own efforts of frantically calling
around bridgeport we found out that
brenda's body was at the medical
examiner's office my family was never
notified by the british port police
department that my sister passed
my family never got the opportunity to
identify my sister's body
let's bring back former detective lisa
lockwood and co-host terry austin as you
look at this proposed law in response to
the death of these two women terry is it
somewhat shocking or odd that there are
no rules about notifying families of
deaths and does this proposed law fix
that problem
well it really is shocking you would
think that there were some procedures or
protocols when you have a death that the
police or authorities or medical
examiner or someone is supposed to
notify the next of candice not as though
they didn't id the body they knew the
name of the individuals both smithfields
and brenda lee rawl so i am surprised
that there is no protocol in place in
terms of how long you should wait before
you notify someone and i think the law
will help solve the problem but not
totally because the whole issue is this
cultural bias the fact that and we don't
know how many times they have not
notified others but if it's because of
the race that's a problem they need to
make sure they treat all of the victims
the same yeah absolutely lisa all right
former swat former detective veteran
your experience goes on and on but so
what are some of the procedures and
rules that you have seen about notifying
family when someone has been either
killed or died
departments do have protocols and
policies there's not a bill that
requires you to do it in a certain way
that just comes down to training and how
you're trained on your job in your
particular agency
agencies have it set up to where is you
make notification in a prompt and
courteous way in person with two
officers as soon as you find out who the
next of kin are a lot of times the news
media gets access to it faster than a
notification can be made because they're
having difficulty with the
identification so it's important yes
this bill is important because obviously
bridgeport connecticut definitely
dropped the ball right we'll see how
this bill affects how bridgeport
connecticut and maybe other cities
around the country go forward with
notifying next of kins that their loved
ones have been lost to them thank you
both when we come back the sarah
lawrence sex cult federal trial long
crimes adam classville reports as both
sides present opening statements in the
high-profile case of lawrence ray
welcome back to law and crime daily
opening statements are presented in
federal court as the accused sarah
lawrence college cult leader lawrence
ray stands trial on charges of abuse and
extortion the allegations date back to
2010 when former wall street trader
lawrence wray moved into his daughter's
on-campus housing at sarah lawrence
after that officials say he gained
control over his daughter's friends
presenting himself as a father figure
and holding group therapy sessions over
the next 10 years he allegedly extorted
money from the students isolated them
from their families and even forced some
into prostitution his alleged crimes
were investigated after authorities
caught wind of a 2019 new york magazine
article revealing the abuse and
manipulation ray faces a 17-count
indictment including charges of
racketeering sex trafficking forced
labor money laundering and tax evasion a
jury was seated on wednesday followed by
opening statements on thursday
vaughan crime network's own adam
classfeld was at the federal courthouse
thursday he joins us now to break down
how both sides laid out their cases in
opening statements
the opening statement of the prosecution
started with a scene from october 16
2018
that began at a midtown motel where
prosecutors say he
essentially put one of these students
through a long night of torture to force
her into prostitution
said that he made millions on this
scheme the defense is trying to
characterize this as something out of
lewis carroll that this is going through
the looking glass and that
rey was a master storyteller and that
the students were fully invested in his
stories one of the quotes that she said
essentially that this was not a
criminal enterprise this was a group of
storytellers
an investigation into a case like this
must be massive but is there any part of
this case that you think would be the
most important to proving lawrence ray
is guilty
i would have to say they're gonna have
to go to the forensics the most
important parts of it are the ads that
were taken out in back page for the
prostitution the photographs his
telephone
all the data and the text coming forward
these are the things that are going to
help prove their case without forensics
we don't have anything obviously we need
to have our witnesses there but we're
going to be running into difficulty from
the person who was the prostitute from
the credibility of their story were they
extorted were they paying money were
they doing it willingly or unwillingly
so the credibility is going to be
attacked without a doubt as it always is
this guy to me is one of the most
sinister characters straight from a
james bond movie yeah now terry lisa
kind of touched on potential defenses
there credibility of the witness being
one of them but what we what have we
learned about rey's defense after
opening statements
well you know a lot of times defendants
in cases try to say okay it wasn't me or
i wasn't there but here he's basically
saying that everyone but himself is
lying he's saying that all of these
allegations by multiple individuals all
of these victims were stories he's
saying that they conspired against him
and they're misguided young adults and
these are friends of his daughter which
makes the case even more difficult to
understand who would move in to your
daughter's dorm there's something wrong
here and how was he able to extort so
much money from each of them so i think
it's an interesting case to say the
least what they're saying is a
charismatic storyteller so maybe he'll
take the stand but of course we'll give
you updates as they progress
well thank you for joining us here on
law and crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you